apfel kurzes intro morgen kommt übrigens
um 14 uhr richtig witziges video ich hab
mir nicht mal die emster direct messages
von meiner freundin angeschaut und die
waren echt mega krank zum teil
morgen 14 uhr in japan etwas klappt
jetzt bekommen beim ein video ja als
nettes schon relativ spät heute aber ich
habe mich hingesetzt kam alex du machst
jetzt doch ein video
weil ich habe megabau zweiten versuch
gemacht ich will wirklich gar nicht
lange lagern
deswegen habe ich jetzt eine kleine
stoffbären farbe zusage 18 sekunden habe
ich zeit und kanal zu erkennen darum
geht ab ich halte das für energiewerte
fertig komm ich ob ich jetzt ein gut und
war kam er letzte woche e10 probleme die
mädchen nicht verstehen oder nur jungs
verstehen ich habe euch aufgefordert
schreibt einen kommentar rechenprobleme
den dino ihn kennt und da hab ich nur
kurz mit ich hab mich mehr gefreut haben
dabei künftig auch leicht bin ich
zufrieden
nein 19 blick um guten lifestyle
scheinverkauf aber eigentlich muss ich
jetzt genau darum dass sie kriegen dass
sie nicht so lang lara auf ihr fall
wir fangen an mit der ersten staffel als
es dann wirklich so viele vergleicht und
dokumentiere ich mehrere folgen waren
auch echt coole sachen dabei die ich
euch jetzt natürlich zeigen vielleicht
sind mir erst mal damit an was ihn am
meisten geschrieben wurde war mir von
vornherein für aber natürlich die tage
und zwar meistens ein kommentar wie
dieser hier jung stellt euch vor ihr
bekommt einen fußball in die
allermeisten der gesagt man darf in die
arktis sowie und jetzt das genauso
schlimm aber jedes was man wissen
deutsch und jetzt das genauso schlimm
aber jedes mal fünf tage lang also das
genauso schlimm halt wie fußball in jaja
aber jeden monat fünf tage lang dann
sitzt der usa wie starke mädchen leiden
müssen so dazu kann ich sofort mal sagen
ich habe falten aspekt für euch wirklich
dass ich mein ich bin eigentlich vor
dass ich wird nicht bekommen weil ich
glaube euch das mega weh tut das kenne
ich auch von freunden das dann immer um
gequengel wird und so hey ich glaub ich
das wirklich
aber immer wenn ich ein fußball oder so
in die eier bekommen
ich mag wirklich fünf minuten auf dem
boden und es tat so hässlich will also
das ist richtig so doll weh tut
nicht mir nicht vorstellen weil dann
würde die einschlägig nur auf boden rum
schießen und euch vor schmerzen krümmt
guter witz dass die haare von mädchen
immer gut sitzen nutzern und fertig wenn
ich meine haare offen sein will muss
sich zuerst wassen füllen
danach sah ich aus wie ein löwe dann
hitzeschutz graf und ganz langsam
glätten und das war wie auch beim ort
darunter leidet im ersten teil dazu denn
natürlich auch um in der
wiederbestellung ganz oben verlinkt ist
sollten wir nach dem video wendet euch
gewehr auf jeden fall anschauen habe ich
gesagt dass jung wirklich manchmal die
haare einfach nicht wetten können man
hat zu diesem bett den man als mädchen
vielleicht auch mal aber das mädchen
kann man halt einfach wenn man lange
haare traut gehen so war meteorit und
ich weiß dass die mittlerweile durch
sehr gute argumentation verläuft total
widerlegt ist also ich glaub mir dass
ihr wirklich lange dafür braucht um halt
coole lange haare zu haben dass diese
schön aussehen wie sie bei den meisten
mädchen aussehen und es tut mir sehr
leid dass ich das gesagt habe
mehr kann ich dazu nicht halt die
christian streiff problem ist das ist
folger weltuntergang geld wenn dein
nagel abbricht und man sich darum
kümmert ob es weh getan hat
punkt um punkt 9 also das ist wird es
dann anfang nicht so schlimm sondern
einfach nur traurig ist dass der nagel
ab ist dann halt mehr traurig als das
video bzw schmerze ihn egal ich habe
diese probleme nicht
ich kann natürlich nicht immer meine
fingernägel aber vielleicht so aber das
machen viele oder ich bin ich glaube ich
bin jetzt nicht allein da wird aber
manchmal schneide ich meine fingernägel
wirklich auch und bei mir ist einfach
noch nie einen nagel abgebrochen
wirklich noch nie
das ist dann wirklich ein problem weil
ich meinen pass möchte man machen wobei
ich da jetzt auch nur sagen kann ich
finde es gar nicht so richtig das
mädchen so gepflegte lange fingernägel
haben einfach normale fingernägel ist
auch vollkommen okay es gibt ja auch der
für sie gehen am 4
und wenn die abbrechen und der lage mit
ab richter zu duschen und mega weg das
glaubt ihr wer gemeint habe auch ich
geil auf jeden fall die luley schreibt
dieser moment wenn die alle jung papier
kirche in den ausschnitt werfen weißt du
was dagegen hilft vielleicht einfach
nicht zeigen
vor der war ganz so schlecht über das
problem habe ich doch jetzt gut
widerlegt oder also ich weiß dann zieht
euch einfach nicht erkannt wo man ein
auto nicht wieder an irgendeinen
topzeiten bisschen höher geht und dann
kann niemand was rein werfen und jetzt
können wir sind wie der 1000 kommentare
warum man das denn nicht machen kann so
hier mal richtig lang kommentar von
denise und wie schreibt also die hat mir
da zehn punkte aufgezählt ich hab mir da
vereinbart zwei rausgesucht und war war
das glaube ich der punkt vier mädchen
sind ja angeblich in mathe chemie physik
und total schlecht und werden dann auch
gleich so abgestempelt meine dafür
können jungs wirklich überhaupt keine
fremdsprache einiger warten gut sondern
ich hatte immer nur leute mein englisch
kurse zu einem spanischkurs da war die
jungs alle grottig schlecht weil die
leute die wirklich aus england kam oder
aus spanien und die mädchen waren aber
wirklich immer die guten und smi kann
ich auch nicht also konnte ist praktisch
gar nichts du das ist dann halt so ein
bisschen auf getrennt jetzt können keine
sprachen mit ihm können keine
naturwissenschaften werdet ihr also
vorurteilen natürlich vorurteil mäßig
mehr ich will jetzt nicht sagen ist es
in wirklichkeit zu ist aber ich hab das
aus meiner schulzeit schon bitten so
mitgenommen dass jung fällt keine film
sparen können und mädchen keine
naturwissenschaft mit dem und weise dass
die jungs oder mädchen im bereich lang
jeweils besser sind außer alex berger
gar nicht teilt und ideen liefern loch
hat geschrieben also die anderen punkte
unterstützt sich alle vollkommen die
kann ich auch gern mal irgendwie in die
kommentare schreiben also danke die
nächst dass du so viel geschrieben hat
auf jeden fall das soll deshalb wirklich
nicht so rüberkommt würde ich versuchen
jedes problem zu widerlegen aber es soll
ja natürlich so rüberkommen als würde
ich irgendwie gegen argumentieren dann
mit ihr wieder gegen argumentieren
können und so weiter aber ich will auch
gar nicht so viel gegen argumentieren
weil erbse möglich mit sehr vielen
sachen recht auf jeden fall hier in
vielen mädchen würde einen jungen artige
tobi oder ein junger beruf viel spaß
machen doch die trauen sich nicht weil
es heißt du kannst das ja so und so
nicht er aber denkt auch einfach mal
andersrum ich meine würde ich jetzt
anfang ballerina zu tanzen oder zu
reiten oder sonstwas würden mich meine
freunde auch erst mal schief angucken
auch wenn sein ist total scheiße ist ich
weiß jeder kann das machen worauf er
bock hat auch bezüglich auf diesen brief
der grafiker auf youtube abgeht kurze
statement von mir eine freude gemacht
ihr könnt für sein können lästig sein
ihr könnt auf jungs sind auch mädchen
nicht genau jetzt war die sd karte voll
ich dir auch mädchen und ich könnte
nicht verstehen wenn man das nicht
toleriert warum auch immer kein plan
aber so lange verborgen aktuell wenn ich
meine rina tänzer werden würde würde ich
auch etwas schief angeschaut werden
auch wenn es eigentlich schade aber es
ist einfach nur das ist von der
gesellschaft so angesehen würde jeder in
der gesellschaft zu denken wie ich dann
werden wir glaube ich viel ich will mich
jetzt auch gar nicht loben oder so aber
ich glaube in ein paar punkten werden
wir ein bisschen besser dran also danke
für deinen kommentar und wir machen
weiter die wird geschrieben das
verwirklichen kommentare hatte auch
finanzieren wird sich leicht also
wirklich argumente hatten viele leicht
aber wie mit kommentar auf und war wenn
deine titten jugend und dass sie nicht
kaufen können was wenn deine waffen und
fähigkeiten können
es entstehen wirklich so auf beiden
seiten durch probleme die beziehen sich
eigentlich in die gleiche richtung aber
da war vielleicht ein bisschen ärmer
dran weil ich meinen wenn man in der
schule sitzt kann man sich mal so eben
unter dem tisch die katzen und bei den
brüsten ist es vielleicht nicht so
einfach bestimmte warten meinen jedoch
von langen stock mit sondern die haben
wir in feldwies blickfeld vor button
fällt nicht in der schule und deine
brüste juckender macht erfolge nicht so
eine macht ist nicht sondern durch idee
okay sei nehme immer weiter zu nächsten
kommentar die leoni schreibt ein problem
für mädchen ist wenn man die ganzen tag
einen dort oder einen job hatte und ihm
die am abend auf macht und dann tut ihr
die kopfhaut weh aber das problem da und
beruf werden vielleicht als
gegenargument wenn meine cap auf hat
dann hat man hier irgendwann immer
solche länder zumindest bei mir dazu ich
hoffe dass sie da ist gefallen
vielleicht doch eine kurze info oder
nicht wegschalten und habe ich vorhin
cooles community formats machen weiter
wirklich sehr dass die jungs mädchen
themen immer mega gefeiert werden und
war habe ich mir eine e-mail erstellt
ich bin ich einfach mal kurz ein und an
diese e-mail die hier steht könnt ihr
eure peinlichste story mit einem mädchen
oder mit einem jungen schreiben und das
klingt dann also vor kommentiert ein
bisschen engagiert hatte in die richtung
weine peinlich
so wie meine peinlichen jungen story
blablabla habe ich irgendwie megawatt
drauf mal sehen was passiert ist ich bin
gespannt bei 15.000 leicht auf diesem
video kommt die erste folge dazu ich
denke mein schaffen war und noch einen
schönen tag
haut rein check bei den stars und dann
wieder viel zu viel raum gelassen denn
das video ist eigentlich vorbei